[Música]
con motivo del 11 de septiembre y 20
años después hoy tenemos el placer de
recibir a javier solana desde madrid ex
alto representante de la política
exterior y de seguridad común de la
unión europea y ex secretario general de
la otan de luton haro javi asur hará que
el cristián labbé javier solana algunas
preguntas el 11-s marcó un antes y un
después en el mundo george bush lanzó su
guerra contra el terrorismo pero después
de 20 años al qaeda sigue activo
surgieron grupos como el estado islámico
y los talibanes ha retomado el poder en
afganistán valió la pena que estados
unidos invadiera con estar en 2001 veía
al organista donde miraba habitaciones
por virtud para decir la verdad yo creo
que en este momento el concepto de
guerra total contra el terrorismo es un
concepto antiguo anticuado yo creo que
en este momento tenemos que movilizar
mucho más a todos los países no
solamente al mundo occidental sino a
todos los demás países para ayudar para
tratar de trabajar juntos en normalizar
una situación que sigue siendo compleja
pero si quisiera decir que me gustaría
que los países que están alrededor de
afganistán por poner el ejemplo último
que son irán de rusia e india pakistán
china todos los países deberían sentirse
también concernidos y es tratar de
ayudar también en la estabilidad de
afganistán
de lo contrario nos encontraríamos en
una situación que ambas que habían
pasado veinte años de presencia
occidentales en afganistán si notado
alguno si no somos capaces de cambiar la
manera de enfrentarnos con la
reconstrucción de afganistán con los
demás países de la región
cometeríamos un gran error
al centrarse en la amenaza terrorista
eeuu ha dejado de lado desafíos como el
auge de china que se muestra 20 años
después más fuerte y dominante que nunca
sin duda la la preocupación número uno
de los eeuu
es las relaciones con china el papel que
china puede jugar en el presente y en el
futuro la relación económica pero
también de manera muy importante la
relación política y yo creo que el
tratar de hacer de separarnos de
desacoplar nos las economías de
occidentales de china sería un grave
error
yo creo para los europeos tienen una
visión de la relación con china que no
es la misma exactamente que la que tiene
eeuu
excepto las 11 al final como los
atentados afectaron a la diplomacia
europea a nivel global
bueno en el 11 de septiembre no cambió
mucho la manera de ver la diplomacia
europea puesto que era un
11 un ataque tan claro tan tan tan
brutal que todos sabíamos lo que había
que hacer todos los países del mundo
reconocieron que teníamos que ayudar a
eeuu ser solidarios con eeuu y eso lo
fuimos unidos desde el primer día y lo
fuimos hasta el último día porque es un
tropas de la otan hasta el final pero sí
es verdad que hubo momentos
entre el el principio y el final unos
momentos en que tuvimos
ciertas diferencias sobre la estrategia
o la táctica a poner en marcha sobre la
revista es legislación final me
bloqueó hugo viana de clip y de
administrar las relaciones del bloque
con américa latina se vieron afectadas
por estos cambios sucesos no geopolítico
no la nuestra relación con el bloque
llaman que esté llamado latinoamericanos
tiene mucho más que ver con problemas de
carácter económico que de carácter
político la parte económica es como
cerrar los acuerdos comerciales en
particular en particular con algunos
grandes países latinoamericanos por
ejemplo todo el problema de mercosur los
grandes países del mercosur grupo
llamado el mercosur llevamos muchos años
trabajando desde el punto de vista
comercial y desde el punto de vista
político pero es verdad que hay que
volver
a recuperar la relación más intensa con
una américa latina que está atravesando
un momento muy malo para la democracia
ésta está decayendo un poco en muchos en
varios países de américa latina habría
que recuperar la relación más íntima
entre la
américa latina en su conjunto y la unión
europea y también nos ayuda no nos
debiera ayudar en la vacunación yo creo
que para la américa latina tiene la vía
problema de vacunas y yo creo que la
unión europea debería ayudar también a
que la vacunación en américa latina
fuera más fácil pues termine sustantivo
es que excepto algún día
puede haber otro 11 de septiembre
no yo creo que no yo creo que hoy con lo
que se sabe con la experiencia que se
tiene un 11 de septiembre sería a mi
juicio muy muy muy difícil de que
pudiera triunfar muy muy difícil yo creo
que no lo va a haber
garcía gracias javier solana por esta
entrevista